big shot I remember reading the story
was you went out with Bianca Jagger and
she was either saying to you you're a
big shot or you were saying to her well
that I know where that story came from I
went out to dinner with Mick Jagger and
he was with Bianca at the time he was
married to her and he was writing a song
uh working so hard to keep you in luxury
you know that song working so hard and
she was kind of putting on the rits a
little bit and he was he he I think he
was kind of bugged with the whole bit
he'd had it with her yeah and then um
that's I was thinking of him singing
that to Bianca Jager not me oh so he had
to be a big
shot oh so that was MC Jagger M and he's
saying to your wife you're you don't you
went up toown riding in your limousine F
par you cloth you know I just pictur
Mick singing it did you tell uh get to
the chorus wait come on don't don't you
had to be a big shot didn't you you had
to open up M there's a lot of
autobiographical stuff in that song too
that's an amazing story so you're
thinking about MC Jagger and his
relationship with the wife and now that
you mention it yeah it is sort of a MC
Jagger is kind of sound this was the uh
the late 70s early 80s and it was the
The Studio 54 thing was going on you
know right and uh you must have hated
that I hated that right you weren't into
that I was the anti- Disco guy yeah yeah
right and so when you write a song like
that do you tell MC Jagger hey remember
the night we went out to dinner wrote
this after that dinner no no I I I
didn't I didn't get a chance to tell him
I don't know if I'd have the audacity to
do that too I did tell some other people
that I wrote songs thinking about them
you might as well tell my audience about
50% of your songs came from just a few
dinners you and I have had you write
about me all the time yeah he you know
he doesn't like to do his own recording
so he slips me the the tape and I I copy
it